Bernie Sanders takes the upper hand in
the Democratic 2020 contest the Senate
impeachment trial kicks into high gear
with John Bolton's revelations and Kobe
Bryant and his daughter tragically died
in a helicopter accident I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
in town my listeners secure their
internet join them at expressvpn calm /
ban we will get to the Kobe Bryant stuff
a little bit later on in the show if you
grew up in Los Angeles it's a
devastating day for you because the fact
is that Kobe Bryant was such a part of
everybody's life yeah I'm from Los
Angeles it's it's obviously a tragic
tragic incident what what the fact that
his daughter was on the helicopter is
just unthinkable we'll get to that a
little bit later on in the show we'll
pay tribute to Kobe we'll talk about
what he meant to the city of Los Angeles
to basketball and general really bad
stuff happening over the weekend we
begin however with the update on your
polls going into Iowa so we are now what
ten days out of Iowa we are very very
close to the Iowa caucuses and right now
it appears that Bernie Sanders has
grabbed the upper hand in those Iowa
caucuses
the current polling has burning up a
substantial percentage in Iowa there are
three polls out they are sort of all
over the place Emerson has Sanders up
nine in Iowa Suffolk has Joe Biden up
six in Iowa New York Times has Bernie
Sanders up seven in Iowa so one of those
poll didn't have to be wrong at least
one of them the the all of those poll by
the way came out inside the last two
days but there's pretty good indicator
that Sanders is coming out on top
Sanders does have the youth vote Sanders
does have the momentum he has a
tremendous momentum in New Hampshire
where the latest polls have him up
double digits in New Hampshire in Nevada
the latest poll actually has Joe Biden
up by like one point which means that
right now the betting markets have
Bernie Sanders as the favorites win the
Democratic nomination which is almost
unthinkable I mean the fact that you
have a man who is a communist for nearly
his entire not nearly his entire career
do you have a guy who is now pretending
to be a Democratic Socialist who likes
Norway but he started off loving
Venezuela and Cuba and the USSR and even
now can't really get himself up for
condemning communism anywhere on planet
Earth that Bernie Sanders could be the
Democratic nominee and in fact has a
solid shot at being at the Democratic
nominee is pretty insane again Bernie
has spiked it dramatically in Iowa and
it's important to remember who Bernie
Sanders is and how a wing of the
Democratic Party could theoretically
take control of the entire Democratic
Party I've said for a long time the best
thing for Donald Trump here is for
Bernie Sanders to win the
because bernie sanders the the election
will become a referendum on bernie
sanders if Sanders is the nominee it
won't be a referendum on Trump anymore
Trump is baked in and people basically
get Trump is out of the box Trump says
dumb weird things Trump doesn't really
get the job in some ways but Trump does
a lot of things that we like he gives us
a really good economy he's been a safer
on the world stage Bernie Sanders is an
out-and-out communist who roots for the
worst people on planet Earth to win all
over the world wants to destroy the
American economy has never met a
government program he doesn't think
should be expanded and has never met a
private industry he doesn't think should
be nationalized it is gonna be so easy
for Donald Trump to turn the election
into a referendum on Sanders the best
thing for Trump is for Sanders to win
the worst thing for the United States is
for Bernie Sanders to win the nomination
the reason being won but then he will
have minimum a 40 percent shot at being
president an actual honest-to-god
accompanist as president of the United
States a lifelong socialist as president
of the United States and also even if
the Democratic Party doesn't love
everything the Bernie is saying they are
now going to centralize around his point
of view in the same way than 1972 George
McGovern ran for the Democrats and
dragged that party dramatically to the
left and eventually that resulted in the
complete takeover of the Democratic
Party by the hard left Bernie Sanders
could do the same thing turning what was
a a not supremely anti-capitalist party
into a supremely anti-capitalist party
turning the party of Barack Obama into
the party of aoc which seems like a
distinction without a difference but it
is a distinction with a difference and
the fact is that Barack Obama was not in
his guts a complete opponents of capital
didn't like it very much but he wasn't
like Bernie a complete hater of
capitalism Obama understands that
capitalism actually generates prosperity
whereas Bernie Sanders believes the
capitalism is ruinous no matter where
it's tried you can tell where Bernie
Sanders is on all of these issues simply
by listening to Bernie Sanders and
listening to his surrogates so Bernie
Sanders over the weekend has been asked
the unfortunate question of how he plans
to pay for all of the things that he
wants to pay for and the man simply
doesn't have any answers along these
lines he's on CBS Evening News with
Norah O'Donnell
and he was asked how he was going to
sell his health care plan and he
basically just said the the Rainbows
will pay for it for claims socialist
democratic put in there please thank you
your agenda has promised free healthcare
for everybody free college tuition
and to pay off people's college loans
the price tag for that is estimated to
be sixty trillion dollars over ten years
correct well we have political opponents
you don't know you don't know how much
you're playing you don't know nobody
knows this is impossible you better
propose a plan and the American people
here are gonna tell him how much it cost
of course I will of course I will he
won't he won't he just didn't he
literally said nobody knows and then in
the same sentence he said of course I'm
gonna tell them how much it cost these
two things cannot live in the same
universe
if you don't know the answer to a
question you don't also know the answer
to a question these are mutually
exclusive statements okay but that is
Bernie Sanders's agenda free everything
paid for presumably by the rich but the
rich don't have the kind of money to pay
for sixty trillion dollars worth of
spending on what he is talking about and
you can tell what is really animating
the Sanders campaign has nothing to do
with his plans has nothing to do with
his spending has nothing to do with
where he wants the country to go what
what really is animating Bernie Sanders
campaign is hatred for all that is it's
hatred for the quote-unquote status quo
and his surrogates say that so Michael
Moore is big Bernie Sanders fan and he's
out there saying that we are like the
French Resistance see it's not what
Bernie is for that matters is what
Bernie is against Bernie is against
capitalism Bernie is against the
American system Bernie's against
American history burning is for a
complete overthrow of the American
system wholesale and Michael Moore is
totally into it here is Michael Moore
characterizing Bernie Sanders his
opposition is basically Nazi esken
suggesting that Bernie Sanders is the
French Resistance which is an amazing
statement given the fact that Bernie
Sanders during World War two if he if he
had been a politically active man at
that time would've been on the side of
the USSR which at the beginning was at
least on the side of the Nazis in any
case here is that's not to say Bernie
Sanders did not see the point is that to
characterize Bernie Sanders his
opposition as not yest and Bernie is a
French resistance member is ridiculous
on his face here is Michael Moore
explaining that he is like the French
Resistance you know we're in the French
Resistance now right right right
[Applause]
you got nine remember the French
Resistance right nobody in the French
Resistance ever said yes I'd like to
help you stop those Nazis coming down
the road there but but um we've got
couples therapy at 4:00 today no no you
have to get along with your spouse for
the next week or two
there's no couples therapy just get
along get along for the greater good of
this country so get out there because
it's like the French Resistance guys and
if you don't make Bernie Sanders the
nominee coming out of Iowa it's because
you are just a bad person who didn't
care about the Nazis well done Michael
Moore also suggests he's tired of
hearing that we are the land of the free
which is a weird thing for a complete
dolt who has made millions of dollars
off the claudus nests of his own of his
own viewer base it's an amazing thing
for Michael Moore to suggest that he is
tired of hearing where the land of the
free while he stands there railing
against the land of the free which is
something that typically does not happen
in dictatorships more Michael Moore on
the campaign trail standing behind a
podium labeled with Bernie Sanders
insignia here he is I am sick and tired
of hearing this that we live in the land
of the free that this is a democracy
first of all you have you you have any
friends in another country or even
Canada where you try to explain to them
we explain to them that the person who
gets the most votes in the democracy
doesn't necessarily win nobody
understands that no for this thing we
need to make so many changes because
it's not just enough for it to be a
political democracy when we get that
part of it fixed the Electoral College
bond the Electoral College makes us not
a democracy apparently according to
Bernie Sanders by the way you should
learn some things about other countries
or very few prime ministers of other
countries actually win a majority of the
actual vote most of them many prime
ministers prime ministers as I believe
Boris Johnson in the latest rounds of
elections I think his party won some
that 43% of the total vote in Israel the
Prime Minister typically wins something
on the order of maybe 20% 25% of the
total vote for his party so the the idea
that it's it's done specifically along
popular vote lines and the person who
wins the absolute majority always wins
like I don't know what he's talking
about but he doesn't know it he's
talking about either the difference is
that he's
I'm critiquing it so that doesn't make a
lot of sense from his perspective the
reason I'm playing you Michael Moore is
because Michael Moore says the quiet
part out loud but Bernie Sanders also
says the quiet part out loud they all
say the quiet part out loud so get ready
I mean again this is the best thing for
Trump running against a Democrat it's
the worst thing for the country if
people start to resonate to this idiocy
we'll get to more of that in just one
second first let us talk about the
simple fact that it is difficult to
predict the future unfortunately you
never know when something bad is going
to happen you never know when god forbid
something could happen to you you'd
leave your family without any source of
income this is why you need life
insurance you need to be a responsible
human being when I first got married one
of the first things I did was to look
around for life insurance you know what
it's kind of hard to find good life
insurance and you think you'll get some
good stuff through your employer the
truth is whatever your employer provides
is probably a fraction of what you're
going to actually need for life
insurance this is why you should check
out policy genius today policy genius
makes finding the right life insurance a
breeze in minutes you can compare quotes
from the top insurers and find your best
price you could say fifteen hundred
bucks or more a year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they can also help you find the
right home auto insurance disability
insurance it is a moral obligation to
get life insurance one make sure your
family is taken care of so if you are
worried about the future which you
should be because you're responsible
human being go get insured against it go
check out policy genius today by the way
they do again all sorts of insurance
they do home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance get covered it's
the responsible thing to do policy
genius.com again get life insurance
right policy genius.com okay it's not
just Michael Moore on the stump for
Bernie Sanders it is also a OC on the
stump for Bernie Sanders so aoc another
popular communist who is out there
suggesting that there's a big problem in
New York City because there are homeless
people in New York see in New York City
and unsold luxury apartments so I guess
her proposal is that we should take the
luxury apartments and give them to the
homeless people which will obviously
create great incentive for developers to
create new buildings that will then be
seized from them by the government and
given to homeless people clearly if you
want to clear up a shortage of supply
the best thing you can do is forcibly
grab the apartments that have been built
and then pass them out for free to
people who are going to piss on the
walls clearly that is going to be the
best possible solution here is aoc
trying to explain that America is evil
because their luxury apartments in her
city of New York City and there are
homeless people on the streets of New
York City and because she's a because
she's a fool she believes that the way
to solve this problem is by taking the
apartments that are unoccupied and
giving them to the homeless people as
opposed to you know creating an economic
structure that incentivizes the creation
of new development units so that there's
a place for the homeless people to go
also ignoring the fact that many
homeless people probably the plurality
or majority of homeless people are drug
addicts alcoholics or mentally ill
here's a aoc just saying silly things
but again silly things are the order of
the day silly things are the order of
the day because we become so wealthy as
a country we have we've become so
incredibly free as a country that people
sit around and they critique the country
that has made them wealthy and free I
mean a OSI has led an ideal American
life truly she went to college she got
an econ degree without knowing anything
which is a pretty amazing accomplishment
she then went and she bar attended and
then she ran for Congress on the basis
of this stellar record and she became a
congress person who now has a luxury
apartment in Washington DC with like a
peloton room that's the American dream
right there and here she is bitching
about it or talking about how America is
terrible and the evidence that America
is terrible is that there are luxury
apartments in New York City that can't
be occupied by homeless people which is
just the dumbest thing in the world it's
like something that my three-year-old
would propose truly it is like when you
are three and you see somebody else with
a thing that you want you just say I
want it and then your parents if they're
a good parent says yes but that's not
yours instead if you're a good boy and
you act well then maybe you'll be able
to get that but that's not the way that
that's not the way that aoc are any of
these folks operate instead it's look
there's this thing I want and because
it's the thing I want obviously that is
the thing I should have and if somebody
else doesn't have something that they
want then we should take it away from
some other person and give it to them
here's aoc not understanding basic
economics but learning her glasses I
guess the glasses make her smart you
know I live in New York City the rates
of people that are experiencing
homelessness or some of their highest
rates since the Great Depression yet one
in every four luxury apartments in New
York City goes on sold there are about
three empty apartments for every one
person experiencing homelessness in New
York City and that juxtaposition of some
of the largest excess next to some of
the worst
gravity is not an accident okay this is
what's hilarious about this is that New
York City is governed by folks on her
side of the aisle Democrats have been
governing New York City for pretty much
forever right there been some Republican
mayor's they were all not particularly
conservative on economics okay and then
you go to LA we have a huge homeless
problem here it's been governed by
Democrats my entire life and you go to
San Francisco which has never been
dominated by Republicans huge homeless
problem Seattle never dominated by
Republicans enormous homeless problem
why it's almost as though there is a
pattern of bad economic policy leading
to homelessness my favorite is where she
says look at all these unoccupied luxury
apartments well clearly that's because
there are somehow disempowering the
homeless
maybe the luxury apartments are not
occupied because everyone who could
possibly provide a tax base is leaving
New York City you idiot maybe the reason
that people aren't getting a luxury
apartment in New York City is because of
the exorbitant tax rates that aosc wants
to force down and the insane business
regulations she would prefer that drove
literally thousands of jobs out of her
district maybe it's because of that but
this is Bernie Sanders economics right
this is this is the future of the
Democratic Party if people don't wake up
in time now here's the problem I think
that almost any way you slice this this
is the future of the Democratic Party I
think the way that you slide really like
no matter where this goes the future of
the Democratic Party is this nonsense
this is where it's going the reason I
say that is let's say the Joe Biden wins
the nomination and then let's say the
Joe Biden loses the election to Donald
Trump the first move will be you didn't
get the passionate people out there you
didn't get the base out we didn't
provide our strongest horse instead we
just went with the moderate again and so
what we really need is we need to swing
over to the Bernie side and then let's
say that Bernie wins the nomination and
he doesn't win the presidency which is
quite likely if he does win the
nomination then it will be ah yes but
that's just the Boomers it's just the
old people because as the young people
age and as they maintain the political
point of view the future is aoc the
future is rashida toledo gets her
shooter to leave in just a second
because you're hearing from camp bernie
and the rest of the democrats this week
it's it's Holocaust Remembrance week
because this is the week that a schvitz
was liberated you're gonna hear from
Democrats this week a lot about the
Holocaust meanwhile they're gonna prop
up or shoot a Talib who was actively
participating in a blood libel over the
weekend with Jay she's also a surrogate
for Bernie Sanders we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
the safety and security of your
neighborhood so my neighborhood is turn
to absolute garbage I
in Los Angeles which means that it used
to be a really nice city now the city
has refused to actually enforce any of
the laws and has prohibited the police
who are trying to do their best from
actually enforcing laws that means the
street crime has gone up it means that
break-ins have gone up it means that
there are people with criminal intent
who may be wandering your neighborhood
and this is true in large cities across
the country
and even if you're living in an area
that's relatively safe why would you not
protect yourself with ringing security I
have rang it makes me feel a lot better
about my property makes my wife feel a
lot better
I've got little kids I don't want people
wondering about my property without me
knowing about it this is why I have ring
ring helps you stay connected to your
home anywhere in the world so if there's
a package delivery or a surprise visitor
you get an alert you're able to see hear
and speak to them all from your phone I
have the ring devices pretty much all
around my house is a subscriber you have
a special offer on a ring welcome kit
available right now and ring calm / Ben
the kit includes a video doorbell and a
chime Pro which is just what you need to
start building a ring of security around
at your home today go to ring.com / Ben
again that's ring.com
/ Ben I love it you'll love it - it'll
make you feel more secure ring.com / Ben
so again this is the Bernie Sanders
campaign with surrogates like aoc and
Rashida to leave over the weekend
Rashida to Lee pushed an actual blood
libel hunt on Ash rally is a
spokesperson for the Palestine
Liberation Organization which is a
terrorist organization and Hanan Ashrawi
tweeted out a story supposedly about a
Palestinian child who was allegedly
kidnapped by quote a herd of violent
Israeli settlers assaulted and thrown in
a water well and then drowned in the
water well that did not happen hey that
is not a thing that happened what
actually happened is that there was a
reservoir in Jerusalem
it rained really heavily and
unfortunately the seven-year-old slipped
and fell in the reservoir and drowned
okay Hanan Ashrawi tweeted out the heart
just shatters the pain is unbearable no
words I mean it was it is an unverified
account that originally tweeted out this
person was kidnapped and executed this
kid was kidnapped and executed by
Israeli settlers now there have been
violent incidents between Jews against
Palestinians before that's the thing
that's happened before but when things
like this happen normally what you'd
want to do is wait for any evidence to
come out hunter Nash rally did not
because she is of course a propagandist
on behalf of an anti-jewish an
systematic terror group Rashid Italy
because she was also a propagandist on
behalf of the antic anti Jewish terror
groups all over the region she also
decided to retweet that show you
this is a this is a blood libel she
retweeted this to her 900,000 followers
and then when it came out that this was
false she deleted it and she said
nothing even hunt on Ash rally had the
sense to issue a half-baked retraction
should my apologies for retweeting
something that's not fully verified it
seems the news of his being kidnapped is
not certain right that not only was it
not certain it apparently never happened
Talib just deleted it and never said
anything because she's a wild
anti-semite because this is the
Democratic Party because the Democratic
Party is willing to tolerate all of this
nonsense ambassador Danni Diane sweetie
I'm always extremely cautious and
criticizing u.s. elected officials
however when an American elected
official retweets an unfounded blood
libel against Jewish Israelis I cannot
remain silent
congresswoman Rasheeda Talib just did
that will receive no media attention
meanwhile you'll hear that Donald Trump
is an anti-semite even as we'll see as
he proposes a peace plan and that is the
first real peace plan for the region in
quite a long time and even though he's
been extraordinarily pro-israel and pro
to his president yeah but these this is
your Democratic Party it's the party of
Rasheeda to leave the party of AOC the
party of Michael Moore this is the
Democratic Party of Bernie Sanders and
Bernie Sanders right now again is the
odds-on favorite to become the
Democratic nominee according to the
betting odds the betting odds haven't
currently at 38% this is a late surge
Joe Biden has run a garbage campaign Joe
Biden did not do any on-the-ground
organizing into the last three months in
Iowa Joe Biden has basically staked his
claim to the presidency on being able to
win South Carolina and Nevada if he
loses the first three if he loses Nevada
he's in serious serious trouble
because bernie is almost assuredly gonna
win New Hampshire if Bernie wins Iowa he
will win New Hampshire Flint Iowa and
New Hampshire there's an excellent shot
that he goes on to win Nevada at which
point it's very difficult to stop the
Bernie train so everybody better hope in
the Democratic Party that it is that it
is Biden coming up from behind in Iowa
because otherwise they are in serious
and then Biden doesn't help himself
because Biden is pathologically
dishonest about his own record so for
example he was hit by Bernie Sanders
over the past few weeks about the about
his views on Social Security not as I've
said in the past when Joe Biden wasn't
running for president he used to be a
somewhat reasonable human being right he
voted for the crime the crime bill of
1994 which was contrary to popular
opinion a very good bill
that helped lower the crime rates in the
United States from historic highs it's
one of the great stories in American
legal history is the decline in crime
between 1994 and 2015 people don't like
to talk about that because that happened
as a result of greater law enforcement
and it's more comfortable to rip on law
enforcement in times of great prosperity
and great peace it is easy to rip on the
sources of the prosperity and the peace
Biden was for that Biden was also in
favor 20 years ago of freezing Social
Security or at least reorganizing Social
Security because he wasn't a complete
and sane person but in the Democratic
Party this is a big no-no so here is Joe
Biden finally admitting yesterday and
guess who's in New Hampshire that he had
talked about a social security freeze 20
years ago but now he says he doesn't
want to talk about that anymore
it's unnecessary because here's the
thing in the Democratic Party you never
speak truth to progressive power this
fight with Bernie Sanders over Social
Security you've said that he quote
doctored video of you from the Senate
back in the day talking about Social
Security but you did argue that
cost-of-living adjustments as part of a
general spending freeze were necessary
to cut federal spending and reduce the
deficit that aside even if Sanders is
playing a little rough here and your
position has changed what about those
Democratic voters who say didn't shoes
okay 20 years ago right say there there
is admitting that's what he used to hope
but the difference is that Joe Biden is
not willing to run on the basis of
actual reasonable positions by the way
neither was Elizabeth Warren who just
received the Des Moines Register
endorsement she throws a little bit of a
wrench into things in Iowa for Bernie if
she starts getting any support but right
now you got to consider that Bernie
Sanders is the person who is most likely
to win at least the first couple of
states P budda judge getting desperate
he thought that he had the momentum in
Iowa and New Hampshire he was asked he
did a Fox News Town Hall and he was
asked about abortion by a pro-life
Democrat and he basically said we have
no place in our party for pro-life
democrats anymore so at least the cats
out of the bag I respect where you're
coming from
and I hope to earn your vote but I'm not
going to try to earn your vote by
tricking you I am pro-choice
and I believe that a woman ought to be
able to make that decision I know that
the difference of opinion that you and I
have is one that we have come by
honestly and the best that I can offer
and it may win your vote and if not I
understand the best I can offer is that
if we can't agree on where to draw the
line the next best thing we can do
agree on who should draw the line and in
my view it's the woman who's faced with
that decision woman will you allow
pro-life democrats in the party and
there he is basically saying no I will
never allow pro-life democrats in the
party this is your Democratic Party no
pro-life democrats full on socialism
America is a bad country open
anti-semites in position of power that
is the Bernie Sanders Democratic Party
so Democrats if that is what you want by
all means go for it just recognize that
number one you are probably conceding
this election to Donald Trump and number
two Democrats you don't believe this
stuff now would be the time for you to
get up on your hind legs and say so it
meanwhile President Trump is wise hey
best thing for Trump is for Sanders to
win the nomination worst thing for the
country's for Sanders to win the
nomination President Trump is running
behind virtually every Democrat in the
national polling right now that's not
true necessarily in the swing states but
banking on the swing states alone is not
a wonderful electoral strategy if you
have any sort of possibility of not
doing that right now according to the
new Fox News polling former VP Joe Biden
is leading Trump by nine points
Bloomberg also has an eight point margin
over the president Sanders has a
six-point margin on Trump Warren is up
by five boo to judge and Klobuchar also
lead Trump in that same survey now again
it's early people have sort of a fond
opinion of Bernie Sanders because
they've never actually done with Bernie
Sanders his positions with that said
it's a Trump is obviously not in a
wonderful position and that position
becomes less wonderful if there happens
to be anything to this impeachment so
the whole purpose for the Democrats here
is not actually to get rid of Trump so
Democrats have been pushing impeachment
because they believe that Trump is going
to win if they don't impeach him but
they can do him damage anyway and they
can hurt Trump and that is why Trump's
best line of defense always and forever
was that Democrats are motivated
Democrats do not like me Democrats hate
me and that because Democrats are
motivated and don't like me and they
hate me they're willing to skew what was
an unfortunate phone call into an
impeachable offense
he never Trump's line of defense always
should have been
yes I tied the foreign aid the military
aids Ukraine to them pushing against
corruption including investigating all
sorts of 2016 election interference
including corrupt activities with
regards to the Obama administration he
should have just said that straight up
and then you should have said you know
what that's not a crime you may disagree
with it you may think it was bad policy
you may think that I'm a conspiracist
but it was my opinion that this was
the interest of the United States public
and therefore I went forward with it
that would be unimpeachable you could
not do anything with it instead because
President Trump has a strategy that
whenever he's accused of anything he
denies it all the way instead he said no
quid pro quo
nothing is the perfect phone cuff the
problem is that it's an unsustainable
position that is not a sustainable
position now the further the first
position is a full-on sustainable
position right the first position which
is this yeah of course I held back the
ad because I was looking at 2016 right
that is a full-on sustainable position
I've been saying this literally all
along and the fact that Democrats are
going after him out of bad faith is
obviously true as well I mean Jerry
Nadler said as much over the weekend and
over the weekend Jerry Nadler said if
you don't remove Trump then he will
become a dictator President Trump is an
outlier he is the first and only
president ever to declare himself
unaccountable and to ignore subpoenas
backed by the Constitution's impeachment
power this is a determination by
President Trump that he wants to be
all-powerful he does not have to repeat
to to respect to Congress he does not
have to respect the representatives of
the people only his will goes he's a
dictator weird enough because I'm old
enough remember when Barack Obama
rejected a subpoena of materials from
Eric Holder and fast and furious and
asserted executive privilege over them
I'm also old enough remember when Barack
Obama suggested who's going to rule the
country with a pen and a phone so yeah
I'm not gonna buy all of us by the way
over the weekend it was reported the
back in 2016 Obama called Trump a
fascist which is hilarious considering
that was coming from a man who wanted
government control of huge swaths of
American life in any case the best
defense for Trump is always the
Democrats didn't prove their case that's
always the best defense because that's
all he has to do right in a prosecution
you don't have to prove that you're
innocent of all charges you just have to
prove that you are not guilty right you
just have to prove that they have not
proved their case and one of president
from slaw yrs basically said as much he
has a word in purpura and this lawyer
Mike purpura he made the case deputy
counsel he made the case that the
Democrats had not proved their case
because all they have at this point is
speculation which is true all the
Democrats have to support the alleged
link between security assistance and
investigations is ambassadors on one's
assumptions
presumption 'he's me and that part is
true
and he says that all they've got is
someone's presumptions of trumps of
trumps intent that part is true right
someone's testified that he thought that
Trump was doing this with with regard to
Joe Biden but he didn't have any real
basis for that supposition right that
part is true the problem is once the
Trump team starts denying that there was
any quid pro quo whatsoever right even
Mick Mulvaney said no he said yeah there
was a quid pro quo it just wasn't an
illegitimate quid pro quo and that was
read by the media to say oh well that
means that he was engaged in bribery no
the question is whether that was
legitimate or whether it was
illegitimate when Joe Biden threatened
Ukraine with a billion dollars in
military aid well the Democrats claim
that was a perfectly legit quid pro quo
so the question is whether that is a
legit quid pro quo or a not legit quid
pro quo the problem is you get in
trouble when you deny stuff that is
obviously not deniable so might prepare
again an attorney for the president
here's where he gets into trouble he
says people were asked who asked Trump
about a link between security assistants
and investigations were told there
wasn't any so here he's trying to prove
a case that he doesn't have to prove
simply because Trump is what Trump is so
Trump insists you go out there and deny
full-scale things that he probably did
and that makes you look bad it makes it
look suspicious as I will explain in
just one moment so here are Trump's
lawyers over the weekend making the case
that there was no connection at all
between the military aid and
investigations of any kind which then
would beg the question okay so then why
are you withholding the military in the
first place like you literally did not
explain why you're withholding the
military aid the answer is very simple
he was withholding the military aid to
look into 2016 had nothing to do with
Biden 2020 it had to do with all
corruption centered around Democratic
Party being favored by the Ukrainian
government circa 2016 okay here is my
prayer though trying to make an argument
that he doesn't have to make the two
people in the house record who asked
President Trump about whether there was
any linkage between security assistance
and investigations were told in no
uncertain terms that there's no
connection between the two when
ambassador the European Union Gordon
Sean hland asked the president in
approximately the September 9 timeframe
the president told him I want nothing I
want nothing I want no quid pro quo even
earlier on August 31 Senator Ron Johnson
asked the president if there was any
connection between security assistance
and investigations the
answered no way I would never do that
who told you that okay well the problem
is then then you have to explain why
exactly the with the military aid was
being withheld again the case that
Trump's you making here is yes I
withheld the military aid yes it was for
investigations the investigations were
in my opinion legitimate and no they
were not about 2020 they're about 2016
now the reason this is important is
because if he had made that case the
Democrats would had no place to go
truly they would have had no place to go
because then he's not actually disputing
anything that is factually provable or
not provable instead he's disputing his
own motive the motive is not provable
right the motive is what's going on
inside Trump's head and if everybody
knows it's weird in there so there's no
way to prove what's going on inside
president Trump's head that would be his
strongest line of defense instead
because he decided to to set up his case
at the farthest available point which is
perfect phone call no quid pro quo
everything fine out to get me because he
did that now he was opening the door to
witnesses as I'm about to explain okay
we'll get to that in just one second
first if you know anything about me
most likely heard me talk about my
ardent support for the pro-life cause
you know I'm extraordinarily pro-life
remember last year I screwed my podcast
live from the March for Life in DC by
the way thank you to all the people who
marched last week really was amazing the
media ignored it even though President
Trump showed up but it's an amazing
amazing event well you may not be aware
of is when I spoke at the March for Life
how much grief has caused us from nasty
political leftists our advertisers were
actually targeted by left-wing so-called
media watchdogs which is to say attack
dogs we've lost a fair bit of revenue
that was not the first time at nor will
it likely be the last time that we are
attacked in an attempt to shut down
pro-life voices and we're not the only
target live action our great pro-life
fighters Lila Rose runs that
organization I personally give money to
the organization they continue to do
incredibly important work in the space
they raise awareness and education on
the abortion issue they do undercover
videos that have exposed Planned
Parenthood and other abortion clinics
for horrific human rights abuses and
social media is constantly attempting to
shut them down so we have partnered with
them so from now until January 31st just
a few more days when you go to daily
wire calm and use promo code live action
a portion of your subscription actually
goes to support that pro-life cause via
live action go check out daily wire calm
and use that promo code live action to
support awareness and education around
the pro-life issue around the world join
daily wear calm make your pro-life voice
heard it also helps protect us
against the nastiness of those leftist
who seek to remove our advertisers in
order to hurt the show when you become a
subscriber you make sure that our
message can continue being pushed go to
daily wire.com it right now and sign up
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so the reason that it makes a
difference where President Trump
presents his defense and the direction
in which Trump presents his defense is
because let's say the trumpet said sure
I was withholding the military aid cuz
I'm one of these investigations because
what happened in 2016 is worth
investigating it is important to know
did the Ukrainians interfere it is
important to know where the Ukrainians
working with the Obama administration it
is important to know all of those things
and you may not like how I went about
that but there's nothing illegal about
that that is a normal part of American
foreign policy let's say Trump had said
that well then today when John Bolton
comes forward with quote-unquote
revelations everywhere we go okay it's
not a revelation we already knew all of
that instead because Trump made the
claim there was no quid pro quo that
military aid was never attempted to be
held back in favor of investigations now
when John Bolton says stuff it's
newsworthy
so John Bolton is coming out with a new
book it's coming out in March this whole
thing is obviously a publicity setup
which makes it look a little bit scuzzy
apparently the day that the New York
Times decided to release its report on
John Bolton's new book the thing went
live at Amazon so obviously that looks a
lot like a marketing pitch that was
given to the New York Times in
conjunction with the sales of the book
the National Security Council
apparently denied that any White House
personnel outside of its purview had
seen the manuscript a former national
security adviser John Bolton's book that
was submitted to the White House for
review White House Counsel Pat's a
Bologna is not part of the NSC so this
isn't a double so this apparently an
on-the-record denial but anyone on
Trump's impeachment defense team
reviewed at Bolton's manuscript which
makes sense because why exactly would
they be making a case that is explicitly
contradicted by Bolton which now means
that the Democrats have a stronger case
for calling Bolton and if the
Republicans had said yeah everything the
Bolton says is true and also that's not
impeachable right then they would say we
don't need to hear from both we already
know what he has to say and by the way
we already admit that what he has to say
is basically true we just disagree on
the motive and he doesn't know the
motive and he never makes any
allegations as to the motive right that
would have taken the steam out of the
kettle
unfortunately for Republicans and for
the Trump team they went out and they
made the case that Trump wanted them to
make which is that everything is
hunky-dory
and that John Bolton is lying so what
exactly is Bolton alleging according to
the New York Times president Trump told
his national security adviser in August
he wanted to continue freezing 391
million dollars in security assistance
to Ukraine until officials that are
helped with investigate
into Democrats including the Biden's
according to an unpublished manuscript
by the former advisor John Bolton okay
number one right there that could be the
defense for Team Trump right because
it's not just we want the Biden's
investigated as we want everything
investigated surrounding 2016 including
the Biden's so does that sound like the
Biden's are the sole target going into
2020 or does it sound like Trump is a
vindictive thin-skinned man who believes
conspiracy theories fed to him by Rudy
Giuliani and wanted to check out 2016
all of which is bad and ugly but none of
which is impeachable right that's the
case I've been making for months on this
program the president's statement as
described by Bolton could undercut a key
elements of his impeachment defense that
the holdup in aid was separate from
trumps request the crane announced
investigations into his perceived
enemies including former VP Joe Biden
and his son hunter Biden who had worked
for Ukrainian energy firm while his
father was in office and by the way
Trump could make the claim if he had
made that case that I'm suggesting him
in that of course we should look into
hundred Biden judas corrupt as the day
is long there's a picture of hunter
Biden today that is emerging in the
media of him getting out of a one
hundred and twenty thousand dollar
sports car with his wife like three
weeks ago hunter Biden claims that
number one he was not the father of a
child by a stripper and number two that
he didn't have the money that he's
bankrupt didn't have the money to pay
for the child support for that kid
allegedly right so that none that looks
great for the Biden's instead because
Trump insists on micromanaging every
element of these defenses and he insists
I'm not just saying okay yeah I
shouldn't have done that but like was it
really bad and was it really impeachable
instead it turns into everything's a lie
outright lie which means that now it's
very difficult not to call Bolton as a
witness and I understand they're
Republicans out there today saying well
the Democrats didn't call Bolton as a
witness in the house that's true
they should have called Bolton as a
witness in the house they should have
and it goes to the Democrats credibility
which is nil but if you're a Republican
and you're running in a purple state in
the Senate do you want to be the person
who said I'm not going to hear from the
key witness whose bombshell revelation
directly contradicts statements by team
from do you want to be that person
that's what the Democrats are counting
on Bolton's explosive accounts of the
matter according to the New York Times
the third was included in drafts of a
manuscript that is circulated in recent
weeks to close associates he also sent a
draft to the White House for a standard
review process for some current and
former administration officials who read
books multiple people
Bolton's account of the Ukraine affair
the book presents an outline of what
Bolton might testify to if he is called
in as witness the white house could use
the pre-publication review process to
delay or even kill the book's
publication or omit key passages just
after midnight on Monday Trump tonight
at telling Bolton the aide was tied to
the investigations and now we have a
direct contradiction between Trump and
his own former national security adviser
which again is going to almost
necessitate that Bolton be called in as
a witness and it's not gonna look good
the problem is that Trump is the worst
defense client of all time the first
rule of being an offense clan is shut
your piehole seriously that is the first
rule of being an offense client if your
lawyer tells you shut up
the answer is shut up don't go on
Twitter and mouth off about things
because now you'll be direct 180-degree
confrontation between John Bolton who by
the way is not a dishonest human being
and Donald Trump who shall we say has a
history of embellishing the truth again
here is what Donald Trump had to tweet
he tweeted I never told John Bolton that
the aid to Ukraine was tied to
investigation into Democrats including
the Biden's in fact he never complained
about this at the time of his very
public termination if Bolton said this
it was only to sell a book with that
being said the transcripts of my car
with presidents Lansky
are other proof is needed in addition to
the fact the president's olanski and the
Foreign Minister of Ukraine said no
pressure and no problems additionally I
met with presidency Lansky at the UN
Democrats had never met and released the
military aid to Ukraine without any
conditions or investigations and far
ahead of schedule
I also allowed Ukraine to purchase
javelin anti-tank missiles my
administration is 10 far more than the
previous administer okay like all the
last part of that is true everything he
says in the last part is true there's
only one sentence there that's a serious
problem for him and it's John Putin's
lying right there John Bolton is only
doing this to sell a book now it may
very well be true that this is going to
help John Bolton's book sales also when
you accuse your own former national
security adviser of openly lying this is
going to make it very difficult for
Republicans to turn down a vote to call
John Bolton as a witness and this is why
you are seeing Mitt Romney already
saying he is likely to back witnesses
Susan Collins and Lisa Murkowski are
likely to back witnesses it is very
difficult at this point for the
Republican senators to say no witnesses
now if this is turned into a purity test
for Republicans seriously it's gonna be
so irritating if there are people on the
right who turn this into you back
witnesses therefore you're just
Republican no that's not the way any of
this works when the president says one
thing and his former national security
adviser says the opposite this is a
matter of interest to the American
people it is the honesty of the
president is a matter of interest to the
American people now does that mean that
anything Bolton says makes Trump
impeachable no does it even mean that
Trump lying is impeachable the answer is
no he was never under oath which is why
it would be insane to put him under oath
and this is why when Trump was saying I
would love to testify you got to be
crazy you got to be absolutely nuts
something it would be a good idea for
Donald Trump to testify which is why
even even from most ardent defenders are
not saying we'd love to hear directly
from Donald Trump because that would be
like the biggest mistake he could
possibly make because then you're in
danger of perjury of course no Trump can
mouth off however he wants the minute he
takes an oath now he's running the risk
of perjury and now you're in Bill
Clinton 1998 territory which is not
where he want to be according to
Bolton's allegations he described how
the Ukraine affair unfolded over several
months he described not only the
president's private disparagement of
Ukraine but also new details about
senior cabinet officials who have
publicly tried to sidestep involvement
for example Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo acknowledged privately there was
no basis to the claims by the
president's lawyer Rudy Giuliani that
the Ambassador to Ukraine was corrupt
and believed Giuliani may have been
acting on behalf of other clients okay
again all of this is perfectly consonant
with stupidity but not with impeachment
so it can be true right I've been saying
all along I think this is what happened
really I've been saying like this in you
can go back and listen to the tapes I've
been saying this since like the first
two weeks of this thing then what
happened is that Rudy Giuliani was being
mislead by a bunch of people with
alternative agendas in Ukraine who's
feeding Trump a bunch of material that
confirmed from pre-existing biases with
regard to 2016 and then those people
were manipulating Rudy who's then
manipulating Trump with regard to doing
certain things like firing Murray
ivanovitch and going after the Biden's
in Ukraine and all the rest of this
Boulton said that after the president's
july phone call with the president of
Ukraine he raised with Ag William Barre
his concerns about Giuliani and told
barter that the president had mentioned
him on the call a spokeswoman for bars a
night he learned of the call from Bolton
the Justice Department said he learned
about it only in mid-august
well again maybe he maybe Bolton raised
it with with bar after bar had learned
about it or maybe he talked with an
assistant we don't really know the
acting White House chief of staff was
present for at least one phone call
where the President and Giuliani
discussed at the Ambassador according to
Bolton Mulvaney has told associates
always step away when the president
spoke with his lawyer to protect their
attorney-client privilege okay in any
case Bolton's lawyer blamed the White
House for disclosure of the books
content the lawyer Charles Cooper said
it's clear regrettably from the New York
Times article published today the
pre-publication review process has been
corrupted and that information has been
disclosed by persons other than those
properly involved in reviewing the
manuscript the White House did not
provide responses to questions about
Bolton's assertions okay bottom line is
again it's gonna be difficult now for
the Republicans to deny Bolton as
witness if he is called again I don't
think is gonna say anything that's
impeachable but it's not gonna be good
for Trump and this is the problem
all right this whole thing was never
about impeaching Trump it was really
about just going after Trump and
damaging Trump and now Trump has damaged
himself because Trump again makes claims
that are not defensible on the merits in
the same way that by the way again it
was not defensible on the merits for
President Trump to say he'd never met
left Parnas he had no idea who left
Parnas was and will have parties who's
read Giuliani's skull douglas associate
in ukraine is is going around dropping
tapes of trump saying things directly to
him none of that makes trumple
particularly honest in all of us my
parents didn't drop a tape over the
weekend of drowning Trump telling him to
take out the Ukrainian ambassador which
is a weird thing to say since again
Murray Ivanovich worked for Trump he
could fire her anytime he wanted the
biggest problem there I think where we
need to start is we gotta get rid of the
ambassador as she still left over from
the Clinton administration where the
Ambassador where Ukraine yeah cheese is
basically walking around telling
everybody wait he's gonna get impeached
just wait like me
and I don't do my animation tag so I
have taken seven that will be now that
we have a secretary okay take her out
okay let's do it okay so the I suppose
easy he can be yeah the idea is he's
talking to partners but we don't know
who else at the dinner so maybe he's
talking to one of his own officials okay
the bottom line is that if you tell
Trump anything that is bad about Trump
in front of Trump front Donald Trump
wins they take the person out right
that's what that's what Donald Trump is
that doesn't violate the law she works
for him he can say whatever he wants in
a private conversation
even with scuzz bags like glove Parnas
but it makes it difficult for the
Republicans to take the full on Trump
has never fibbed about anything
everything is on the up and up
everything here is hunky-dory
line because Trump refuses to defend his
own line he refuses to defend what he
actually did this is why when people are
all over Mitt Romney about all likely
back witnesses as I've said all along I
don't really care about witnesses I
think the American people generally have
a right to disclosure and I'm consistent
about this if this were Barack Obama I'd
be saying the same thing I would love to
hear from witnesses and that include
hunter Biden and yes it would include
john bolton this notion by republicans
that it's some sort of failure of purity
if you don't want to allow if you are
okay with allowing witnesses when the
president is directly contradicting as
honest and a Sano by that I also don't
buy that anything that Bolton is
claiming is actually impeachable anyway
here's MIT Romney who is taking so so
MIT Romney came out he said that he
would likely back witnesses I say there
are other Republicans who said they will
likely back witnesses all of this could
have been a lot easier if the defense
attorneys for Donald Trump had told
their clients to stop this and stop it
and be quiet and let us handle this
because guess what the Democrats did not
prove their case I mean even Jeffrey
Toobin over the weekend before this bolt
and stuff even Jeffrey Toobin was saying
the Republicans are winning and the
president is winning the Republicans are
winning here the president is winning
here and as long as they don't you know
completely fall on their faces which
they're all competent lawyers they're
not going to do that I think that's fine
for them and and that of course is right
that's right now we're gonna have
witnesses now do the witnesses mean that
anything fundamentally changes no it
doesn't mean any of that nothing's going
to fundamentally change here with that
said there's any of this great for
president Trump looking forward to
re-election
is not and it is the best thing that
could happen to somebody like Bernie
Sanders who again is making the case
that anybody can be Trump including an
open commie at this point I mean well
very quick update on the corona virus
situation so the the corona virus
situation continues to grow according it
to the Chinese we now have over 80
deaths from the corona virus draconian
travel curbs have been implemented some
50 million people in China have been
barred from travel there apparently five
cases in the United States of
coronavirus apparently also it is
communicable before symptoms show which
is scary because you can have somebody
who has it doesn't know they have it
they're already passing it on to other
people you know as far as how deadly
this is and how much of a risk it is to
the United States right now they're
saying worldwide the number of confirmed
cases is nearly 2,000 I think that it is
important at this point to point out
that the seasonal flu in the United
States that the the flu was was obtained
by something like 3.7 million people in
the United States in 2019 3.7 million
cases of the flu between 23,000 and
41,000 hospitalizations and somewhere
between 1300 and 3300 flu related deaths
in the United States just between
October 1st and December 7th 2019 so
when we talk about the corona virus and
the threat of the corona virus just
recognized that there's flu epidemics
every year and a lot of people die from
those flu epidemics is this a situation
for panic no is it a situation where
crackdowns on travel are necessary you
bet you bet and we ought to keep an eye
on it obviously okay time for a quick
thing that I like and then a quick thing
that I hate so things that I like today
so President Trump this week is going to
propose his peace plan in the Middle
East it's going to recognize some very
simple on the ground realities realities
like the Jewish quote unquote
settlements in Judea and Samaria which
are not illegal under international law
there's nothing that says the Jews are
forbidden from settling in areas of
Judea and Samaria that are not only
historic Jewish territory but a disputed
territory under international law
thanks to conflict the the peace plans
of the past had always assumed those
would remain Israeli territory president
Trump is going to maintain that those
that those areas remain Jewish in any
sort of deal which of course is what is
going to happen the reason that that is
actually smart is because if you wish to
put pressure on the Palestinians to come
to the table one of the things you say
listen all the territory that the Jews
are going and grabbing by assembling
there all that territory that's not
coming back off the table so the faster
you make peace and you grab a
territorial and you grab a territorial
final settlement here the better off you
are going to be the Palestinians of
course have never intended on making
peace under any circumstances the great
lie of the media and of the left is that
the Palestinians have been desperate for
peace that is of course untrue on every
level
they've been militating in favor of the
destruction of the State of Israel
consistently and without without break
since the creation of the State of
Israel the Palestine Liberation
Organization unless we forgot was
founded in 1964 before the 1967 six-day
war which means that what they were
attempting to liberate quote-unquote was
Haifa and Tel Aviv not Jerusalem right
not not the West Bank which was at that
point covered by Jordan so all of this
is a recognition of reality the Trump
administration does recognize the
reality on the ground with regard to the
State of Israel the White House is
hoping that it can get the support of
both Benjamin Netanyahu the current
Prime Minister and pentagons who is his
lead rival for the prime ministership
and that would provide some momentum
gods would be a fool to turn it down you
survived a tainted leader avi joe
lieberman who sort of the swing vote
over there he made comments about both
Netanyahu and God's his gold seal
without reading the plan Trump will
present today I have no doubt it will
have a true understanding of Israel's
interest in a future settlement with the
Palestinians from Netanyahu it is clear
that this is part of a survival plan and
nothing else now one of the great lies
here is that the Trump administration is
trying to prop up Netanyahu as opposed
to simply providing a real plan and I
know a lot of the players on both sides
with regard to this suffice it to say
the pentagon's does not have significant
disagreements with Benjamin Netanyahu on
foreign policy which I know comes as a
great surprise to the idiots at the
Editorial Board of the New York Times
suffice it also to say the Trump
administration they like Bibi
but if God says the Prime Minister
they'll deal with him too they don't
really care they've been having ongoing
talks with cons so the so the the
silliness that this is all a method of
propping up Bibi is obviously untrue
meanwhile Palestinians are responding to
any peace plan with another Day of Rage
which is called Tuesday in in the in the
West Bank and Gaza Strip when you
provide your people with no jobs seal
all the money and use it to build terror
cells it turns out that people get
pissed off pretty easily okay
time we'll bring in more details on that
plan when it is finally released and
when the media ripping up and down
because the media are corrupt and don't
understand the first thing about Middle
Eastern politics okay time for a quick
thing that I
okay so obviously the thing that I hate
today is this awful awful news out of
Los Angeles Kobe Bryant and his daughter
among nine others were killed in this
awful helicopter crash that happened
over here just off of Las Virgenes
apparently the sort of best available
information at this point suggests it
was likely pilot error and not
mechanical failure although I'm sure we
will get more information about that as
time goes on it was very foggy yesterday
apparently particularly the area where
the plane crashed it's very hilly so
that means that if the helicopter pilot
could not see the the landscape because
I guess the helicopter pilot was flying
beneath the cloud cover and so if it got
real foggy he couldn't see all of a
sudden gets disoriented just an awful
awful story Allison I'm a Celtics fan so
that meant that I spent most of my
childhood hating Kobe because he was a
Celtics killer right I mean there were
there was at least one championship that
Kobe was responsible for stealing from
Boston he was a player where if he
wasn't on your team you loved to hate
him and if he wasn't on your team you
loved to love him there was nobody more
beloved in the city of Los Angeles than
Kobe Bryant he's also somebody who seems
to have grown over time obviously he had
a bunch of personal issues very early on
in his career by the time of his death
and his daughter being on the helicopter
is just devastating I mean just the
worst thing in the world 13 years old
just horrific in every way there's this
tape that was going around yesterday of
Kobe talking with his daughter Gianna
she was the one who was on the
helicopter with him and there they were
talking a basketball game he obviously
was really proud of her this is just a
not very long ago at all on Jimmy Kimmel
talking about his daughter Gianna
carrying on his basketball I guess he
shoes aboard the helicopter as well do
you think your daughter might want to
play in the WNBA she does for sure she
died I don't it means this is this kid
man what happy great
[Applause]
the best thing that happens is when we
go out and fans that come up to me and
she'll be standing next to me and be
like and you gotta have a boy you and
Vee gotta have a boy may have somebody
carry on the tradition the legacy she's
like oh yeah I got this there's a tape
of them a couple of weeks ago sitting at
a Lakers game and they're going over
strategy and you can see it's it's
really quite charming he's talking with
her she's finishing his sentences you
can see is proud of her for how she's
analyzing the game yeah he obviously was
a good father a caring father has tons
of tape of him online talking about his
kids and playing with his kids they had
four kids he and his wife it's just just
on a human level
it's truly awful and whenever obviously
somebody who touches this many people
you know it's people always it's easy to
say a celebrity died who cares the same
thing as anybody else dying the reality
is that celebrities do touch people's
lives because you make them a part of
your life AG now it's just awful it's
just so terrible when when somebody
who's a celebrity dies you shouldn't
feel bad about feeling terrible about it
they are a part of your life there's
somebody you spent time with there's
somebody welcomed into your home and the
fact is that even if you love to hate
Kobe as a player the man was an
unbelievable basketball player and it
seems like a pretty terrific father hit
you know in the last couple of years he
retired he'll be I'm sure inducted in
the Basketball Hall of Fame what's that
worth you know posthumously he hears a
little bit of tape from from Kobe's last
game he retired his final game of course
was a very Kobe game right he scored 60
points in his final game he was leading
a very bad Lakers team to a victory in
that final year and he was badly injured
a couple of years before he retired
here's a little bit of footage from
Kobe's last game who got that
a two-possession game
there's his 19th Gorski
[Applause]
so last night in the NBA they're a bunch
of teams because he's number 24 there
are a bunch of teams that traded
24-second violation for folks who don't
watch basketball you have 24 seconds to
bring the ball down court and take a
shot and hit the rim and and so they're
a bunch of teams all around the NBA
where they opened the game by dribbling
out the clock to 24 seconds and then
they were and then the other team would
take the ball and dribble out the clock
obviously it was it was a terrible story
when you found out that that Kobe was on
the helicopter the story got an enormous
amount worse when he found out that his
daughter was on the helicopter as well
you just got a feel for the family today
you got a feel I mean really stuff like
this is so far apart from politics that
it's not even worth discussing politics
there are people today who are very
upset with Trump for having tweeted
about it that's very silly again
obviously when somebody who's a major
figure dies and whether you like Kobe or
where they didn't like Kobe that was a
major figure when that happened yeah
it's worth taking time to actually pause
and appraise especially because it is
true that we spend an awful lot of our
lives sort of denying the reality of
what's coming for all of us
and when something like this happens
really suddenly it's really it's really
quite quite awful and really you know we
should all be praying for the Bryant
family tonight particularly his wife who
lost not only a husband but also lost a
child which is just the most unthinkable
thing that can happen I'm a parent as
well you're if you're a parent you know
that the even the thought of that it's
like the worst thing could possibly
happen and because I'm from Los Angeles
this is you know a big thing in LA I
remember I mean yesterday I haven't got
a kid's birthday party and the news
started to go around the kid's birthday
party it was it was pretty awful I mean
the whole thing is really really awful
so again prayers for the Bryant family
and you know burners for all of us
really really bad stuff alrighty well we
will be back here a little bit to a
little bit later today with two
additional hours of content otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
you
on the Matt Walsh show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation